it's because i had chlamydia twice and i
got like my tubes all scarred up it's
like [ __ ] up in here
and so i want to adopt a baby huh it's
an std
have you had it i'm pretty sure you've
had it it's a french restaurant
no you guys are good with babies because
they'd be like really pretty and really
talented like it'd be funny it'd be
beautiful like yeah like you should have
maybe you feel some type of way
if when you hear someone like me saying
like oh i have had like two abortions
no not really i don't judge like that
thing because like i totally get it like
you know
it's like you should have a baby you
don't want a baby but at the same time
i'd be like oh if you want to like sell
me your baby
i would totally have it i might be open
to that because i
the first pregnant the first time i got
pregnant we had only been together like
a month
oh wow and i was like not sure about him
uh and wow because we hadn't really we
weren't even official yet
like as a couple we weren't facebook
official you know who makes more money
he does at the time too yeah i was a
nurse then
oh wow well that means you have a good
character because honestly well i don't
hold her you're younger older than me
i'm
36. oh my god you're so yeah i mean i
thought you were like way younger than
me i thought you were like 26 or
something like that because like me at
like 25
if i got pregnant by someone that was on
tv whether they're rich or not because
it doesn't always mean you're rich
like i've been with people out of my
math tv and they're like broke you know
what i mean
you know who they are i can't i didn't
you know you don't think you're up to
say you know
he's nice he's nice i already know what
it is okay yeah i know and i'm gonna say
the name
no no and then we'll bleep it out
andre's getting ready right wow so
let me ask you this um so
a tongue twister worries like he'll [ __ ]
anybody and i was like oh
like so trish what you were saying was
if you had been gotten pregnant by
either of those two men you would have
kept it for sure
if it was like in the like that was my
goal when i came to l.a because i was
like so broke for so long and i like
just wanted to have a baby because i
knew so many girls
like everybody
always tells me he's like you are the
dumbest this could not have trapped his
ass twice
seriously you know two opportunities to
travel abby
my manager said that like you're so dumb
you would have been set for life that
monthly paycheck like [ __ ] it yeah i
[ __ ] up
honestly it is iconic like if someone
gets pregnant by like a really rich
person like iconic like good for you
like i honestly like
a woman like she's probably like living
large in like kentucky or wherever she
moved to
and i think that's awesome i really do
think that's awesome because that's what
i wanted to do and i couldn't achieve it
yeah yeah or like drake
drake's oh right yeah oh my god he likes
like
thick girls i missed my chance with him
too i was like yeah you were you could
have been interested i know
i know when i see that i was like the
little baby i was like oh that could
have been my baby
okay that little blond curly hair you
know how scary that is
i mean that's why i think maybe that's
why i'm you know i've always been in
long-term relationships
yeah because i'm afraid of those [ __ ]
traps it's you should be and other
people should be too they're so stupid
like when a hot chick is like going hey
you want to hang out
that would be it now that's probably a
feeling i think you've always been
careful you dated a lesbian
for years really he did that
that's how safe he was yeah wow do you
guys have sex
i needed a gay guy so i'm totally really
happy did you have sex with him he
[ __ ] me really weird yeah and he hit
me
yeah oh did she like sucked you in the
face i mean he was the most abusive guy
in the world
really yeah because he was claws he was
a closeted man
it was his beard and then he wouldn't
admit it to the world and we we
we wanted to cut this out but you've
always sort of been with like
boyish women though like you know god
what are you talking about
like you're androgynous i'm considered
you know especially in my younger years
i had like a boxier shape i had muscles
like you like girls either long chins or
like muscles
yeah yeah yeah like wonder woman types
like matt like a little bit like
i like long faces you love long i love
long faces oh so that's a compliment
then like long faces when you said
earlier like the scream face that's like
hot tv yeah that's hot to me
because my face is so circular
i think like i've said this before i
think what i'm looking for is the
opposite look at that that's
her fiance wow that's his type it's
jesus
he looks like dude that's what jesus
looks like right yeah